they've touched our hearts they've made
us smile
and became dear friends
who we will always remain hopelessly
devoted to
John Travolta in tears paying tribute to
his beloved Greece co-star Olivia
Newton-John
Sandy
because there was only one person in the
world that was Sandy and that was Olivia
Newton John the actor makes a special
appearance at the 2023 Oscars to
introduce the in memoriam segment
featuring a performance from Lenny
Kravitz in this industry we have the
rare luxury of getting to do what we
loved for a living
and sometimes getting to do it with
people that we come to love
and since tonight is a celebration of
the work and the accomplishments of our
community in this past year it is only
fitting then that we celebrate those
we've lost
part of John's intro paid special
tribute to the late actress even
borrowing an iconic lyric from one of
Olivia's performances in their 1978
musical film Greece
[Music]
they've touched our hearts they've made
a smile
and became dear friends
who we will always remain hopelessly
devoted to
so here with to honor them with a very
special performance please welcome
incomparable Lenny Kravitz
[Music]
is this the jacket this is the jacket
this I've maintained we won't talk about
the pants
this year's in memoriam honored many
actors actresses and filmmakers who had
won Oscars or were nominated during
their careers including Kirstie Alley
Ray Liotta Irene Cara Raquel Welch and
many more
[Music]
yes
but some names were left off the list
like Tom Sizemore and Hayes Leslie
Jordan and Paul Sorvino causing some
fans on social media to show their
disappointment
foreign